We put a master swordsman
in front of a table full of blades.
This is what a character might do
with these weapons.
This is Meldof’s hammer.
Yes
Welcome back to a special episode of Punch
4 Punch.
You guys at home
and Netflix seem to like us. So?
We’re back!
And we're back to talk about Blood Origin,
The New Witcher series coming up.
It has cool sword fights
and axe fights and dagger fights.
We want to figure out
what's the magic sauce to make the stuff
look good on screen.
So we invited our friend Luke La Fontaine,
expert swordsman choreographer,
to join us.
And we put a master swordsman
in front of a table full of blades.
There's some weapons here that are similar
to the weapons in the show.
Why don't we get right to it,
pick them up and start using them?
Well, actually,
before we get right to it, I know
this is a special Punch 4 Punch episode.
But you got to start
off with the right tone.
Hit em with it!
Hey, what's up, guys?
So we are going to be taking a look
at some of the fight scenes
here from Blood, Origin and Luke.
You know everything
there is to know about swords, right?
Maybe, yeah.
Especially when it comes like filming it.
So I want to get your break down
on all this.
Absolutely. I can't wait to watch it.
Luke real quick,
tell us a little about yourself.
Ever since I was about seven years old,
I was obsessed with swords.
It took me to Japan, it took me to Europe.
I was fortunate enough to study
with a number of different masters.
16 years old, I did my first film,
which was the original Karate Kid.
That was my first experience
into the world of stunts.
I decided I was going to come out
to California and become a stunt man.
And here we are, 39 years later to enable
me to be here with you guys today.
And, you know,
I always cherish being able to talk about
what I love with good friends.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, let's jump into a scene.
Fight as a clan.
We may just make it out
alive.
Right off the bat.
I love what they're doing with this.
It makes brilliant sense
in terms of the people
with the larger weapons and the shields
are at the front of the line defending
and the elf that's got the doubled smaller
daggers is behind doing cleanup.
This is very, very realistic combat.
And I like it.
They're actually literally tactically
doing things that would make sense.
They're throwing spears, daggers.
The sword strikes are for vulnerable
parts.
There was a guy on top of that table,
Michelle Yeoh cut his legs out, boom.
He hit that guy in the neck.
Why? There's a gap in the neck, right
where the axe would be able to go.
They also start with sword and shield.
They don't end with sword and shield.
Exactly.
There's an evolution to the characters
and it just adds more
drama
and makes us care about these characters.
The story of the fight goes
somewhere, right?
And the audience gets
to go there with you, which is awesome.
You've gotten rusty.
Have I?
Fights like this are so much harder to do.
Oh, yeah.
You're dealing with so many elements
at the same time.
How do I make this look believable
between three people?
And everybody
is getting the right amount of time
so that somebody is not left out.
I have to admit,
I would have been intimidated
and gone “uhh”
scratching my head going, okay,
Michelle,
I'm going to need your help on this a lot.
Right.
Out of the three of them,
she is probably the most skilled,
not only as an actress performer, but
as the character that she's portraying.
So therefore, it shows
that she's constantly controlling,
still moving everybody around her
and keeping everybody safe
while still proving her dominance
over them.
She's
using their hot headedness against them.
And what's great
is that's being very clearly told.
You got to love when like somebody does.
The typical master thing like,
I'mma beat you with a sheath or twig
against your blades.
That’s a bold choice to start with,
boom again, really smart.
Look at the armor design.
Look at the placement of her blades.
She's cutting people
where the armor isn't.
She's moving.
Yeah, she's not staying stationary.
She's getting out of the way
of these characters.
Getting a lot of the actress herself
actually doing moves too.
It's great using doubles when you can,
but like you need an element of the actor
being physical and getting in there
just to earn the character.
Every time you see an actor or an actress
put that work in, it's besides it
being believable in the storyline,
you wind up respecting
and defending that actor because you know
that actor put that extra work in.
Oh, look at that guy, huh?
You did some flourishes Okay. Yeah.
What did we do? Somebody’s
been paying attention.
What did we do in To The Death
and what do we see?
I'm going to do a bunch of sword
flourishes.
I'm going to wind up paying for it
because he wasn't having it.
So we looked at all the choreography,
the tactics, techniques here,
but we didn't talk about the weapons
themselves.
Luckily, we have the master armor,
Nick Jeffries, to teach all of us
exactly what was his process
in making these amazing weapons
that we see
being swung around in this amazing show?
Let's go talk to him
and learn about why he made the decision.
Oh, yeah, I'm dying to see that.
So we are on the line with Nick Jeffries
here.
Nick, thanks for joining us.
Could you tell us a little bit
about yourself?
Yeah, sure. My name's Nick Jeffries.
And I'm the master armor
for The Witcher and its spinoffs.
What a cool job title.
Can you tell me a little bit
about what you did on Blood Origin here?
Did you make the weapons?
Did you help conceptualize them?
Every stage is mine.
I read the script, write down
who needs the weapon, and then we come up
with the finished item.
We have the hero weapon that's real.
So if it’s stationary, lying on the table,
holding it.
If it's really close up,
we use the real one.
In all other situations we use rubber.
What was the inspiration behind the weapon
designs that you did for Blood Origin?
What I did with Blood Origin was push back
into more ancient swords from Bronze
Age weapons, but we have used steel
because they have that technology.
This is actually the Soul Reaver,
the Holy Weapon that the quest is for.
This actually has a bronze core in it,
but it has a steel outter.
But the bronze is a direct connection
with the bronze in the blade Any body
you kill, you have a direct connection
in the bronze to them.
I love that.
That's cool. Yeah, that's super cool.
All that worldbuilding.
Wow. That's a sick axe.
Yeah, that's Fjall’s big axe. Now that,
as you can probably hear, is hollow.
It doesn't look like it's hollow,
but it's made out three mil plate.
If we made this solid, you can imagine.
It would be like 14 pounds.
Plus being steel.
It lets me get some proper
looking age to it.
I would like to claim this stuff.
It's not in a museum
because nobody's found it yet.
But if we made it really rusty
and put it in a hole in the ground.
They’d go “Oh, fantastic!”
What I want to show you next actually
is the only dedicated Dwarven weapon.
So this, is Meldorf’s hammer.
It's called Gwen,
which is Meldorf’s murdered girlfriend.
She talks to this.
These things
here, that actually says GWEN on the side.
So we've made it like they’re
both screw caps
and it's hollow inside
and it contains the ashes.
Oh, wow.
Everything is perfect in my mind for her.
Perfect person playing the perfect role.
And then we managed
to give them the perfect weapon.
So I'm really
happy with how that came out.
All the different weapons you
have in there from Blood Origin,
if you were in that world
and you had to go into battle,
which weapon would you take with you?
I like the daggers that were Éile’s
because they have this ring on the end.
Yeah.
And once you have a ring,
you can do so much more with that.
If you can use something for real
it would probably be this dagger,
of everything we made.
Well well, Nick, thank you.
Thank you so much for taking the time.
Like every time you would step away
and bring out another blade, we’d
always be like “Yes, yes, yes”.
That's so true.
See, this is the thing about armory
and the way we do it, really.
You've just had a little insight
into our unusual world.
I love it. Yeah.
Thank you. Yeah, that's amazing.
You're welcome. It's a pleasure.
All right.
We learned about these weapons.
Now, Luke, will you show us
how to make them look good on camera?
Absolutely will, let's go have some fun.
Luke, on this table in front of you.
I have three weapons,
weapons that are close approximations
to what are in the show
because the actual weapons are often
anglon.
So we've got the closest thing we could,
but I was hoping you could show us
how to make these look cool on camera.
Let's unveil the first pair.
under the red veil.
We have daggers.
Not a problem.
Boom. Here we go.
We've got a pair.
Not exactly matched of Kukris.
If we're talking about practicality
in terms of combat,
both forward is the most practical way
to use these weapons,
but it's a fantasy show, so screw that,
we aren’t doing that.
My cutting patterns.
X’s, Horizontal cuts, upward cuts.
If I make a combination where I cut down,
I cut across, I cut up, I cut down,
I can come up with any kind of pattern
I want to come through here
and cut somebody. And stab.
There's no limit on how they can be used.
In terms of a fantasy piece.
I might be able to demo
a little bit further
if I have another weapon
for these to go against.
Luckily, under the yellow cloth we have...
broadsword. Is this called a broadsword?
Yeah, technically, that is a Chinese Dao
or Chinese broadsword.
This is very, very typically
a military weapon in ancient China.
And for the show it's very similar
to Michelle Yeoh's character sword.
You notice that's a steel sword.
Yeah, it's a Wushu practice sword,
which means it's not sharp,
but it's still steel
and it's got a thin edge.
So we're going to be careful
in how we use it.
Here in the States, we're a little bit
more on that cowboy edge.
We will mix materials where in England
they won't.
But I believe as part of the Declaration
of Independence, it said...
“But we also want to be able to use
metal weapons in our martial arts scene.”
So yeah, right, right.
And that's written in there somewhere,
you know, it absolutely is.
So we have a dance partner here for Luke
because Gui and I we're
just going to be watching and talking.
So Stephen Dunford, if you can join us,
you guys have watched the To the Death
short film on the Corridor Channel.
Steve is one of the guys
with the energy swords
And that's why he's here today
to put his hands on that sword,
because I trust Stephen Dunford
not to split my head open.
Okay, so this is what a character might do
with these weapons.
He cuts vertically at my head, bang.
Now I'm doing what's called an X block.
When I oppose with both weapons,
I'm scissoring the blade in between
both blades.
So there's nowhere for the blade
to slide off to.
I want to take advantage of this
and use one weapon to attack
and one weapon to defend.
So I use my right hand to slide the weapon
off out of my trajectory
and make a cut on him where he's
going to take a diagonal cut down at me
and we both miss
he makes a horizontal cut.
I can parry double
which puts a wall of steel in between me
and the other blade.
I can also do the exact same x block
if I choose to
and deliver a fatal blow.
Okay, so you showed us
some cool moves with daggers.
So now we're looking at this blade here.
You know,
this is basically the equivalent
of the sword that Michelle Yeoh
is using in Blood Origin.
How would you amp this up and make it
stylistically look good on camera?
If I was going to draw this weapon,
I want to present the sword.
Once I draw the sword,
the sword wraps around my body.
Chinese
Daos are about keeping the sword moving,
mainly because in a lot of instances,
military combat.
You're not fighting one on one.
You're in a battle
with hundreds of people.
If I keep the sword tight to myself,
I can parry
and keep myself wrapped in steel
while I stab and cut other people.
It's a light, agile weapon
with a broad blade that's really sharp.
So you showed me how to use this weapon
kind of in a personal way,
but I'd love to see
this used cinematically in a fight, even
just like a five or six demonstration.
You got to oppose this with something.
Let's use something
we haven't seen. Well, perfect.
Because under the blue cloth, we have.
Oh, boy. Ooh. That one's mine, right?
Yes. You can have that one.
Oh, wow.
This actually has a lot of weight to it.
Yeah, that's a steel axe. Well, here
you go, sir.
This character swords already in
the sheath hasn't been drawn out yet.
This character doesn't know
that this person is going to attack them.
And the fight starts and he decides to
thrust the axe forward at me.
I block
with the sword still in the scabbard
and shoved the blade down.
He decides to cut up.
I evade backwards.
He cuts diagonally.
I decide that it's time to use the sword.
Now I pull the sword out, bind the sword,
hit him in the back with the sheath
and prepare for a fight.
So I can't help but notice
that you guys have a certain body language
where it's like.
It's almost like
you just telegraphed things a little bit
with your shoulders, with your hands.
My body movements match the movements of
the sword, but also I'm telling a story.
Stylistically, I could do all the same
movements that I did without that,
and it would look very boring.
Everything would be very square.
I'd pull the sword out and kind of
just stand back and be ready to fight.
So the idea is if you've got a performer
who is amazingly physically capable
and is comfortable with a weapon,
let them rock and roll a little bit.
Then you can develop it, then you can mold
it, then you can say, Hey, I love that.
More, more, more
or less, less, less here and there.
All right.
So you made that sword look really cool,
but what about this axe?
Let's take this axe
and let's make this our primary weapon.
How do you make an axe
look good on screen.
Whenever you see a big, giant axe
like this in movies or television,
you always see this big kind of brutish-
I'm going to take this huge
swing and cleave you in half.
Axes weren't actually used that way.
This isn't a super fast weapon to recover.
You can kill me.
Now, now, now, now, now, now.
Maybe now I have a chance, right?
The idea is this is a bullying weapon.
I stay what's called in my box.
So as a martial artist,
I stay in the confines of my body.
I harass, I can move the weapon around,
I can hook, I can stab.
And these points are called the horns.
So a lot of times you'll see axes where
on this axe, it's almost symmetrical.
I use that to poke into your face
and you don't like it very much.
The other thing about an axe is,
look how wide the head is.
So when I'm standing here
defending myself,
I've got all the steel in front of me
to pick up other people's weapons
and keep you from hacking me in half.
So let's do a short demo between
that sword
and this axe to give you an idea.
Good luck, Steven.
We're rooting for you, buddy.
Stephen does a vertical cut.
Boom.
I dispel
that. Stephen does a diagonal cut.
I get the hell out of the way now.
Same thing.
He makes a flat, horizontal
cut at me. Bang!
That's what this weapon is great for.
I have the advantage.
I can do all kinds of nasty things
to Stephen as a reply with this weapon.
And you saw it in
some of the footage we watched.
He's not taking these giant swings.
When he takes some of those guys out,
he goes, bang, he takes that guy's leg
and just yanks him and he drops
to the floor because economy of movement.
If you're utilizing an axe in the way
it's supposed to be used
and now you're doing it on film in order
to make that feel interesting, is it a lot
about showing the unique traits
of that weapon in your opinion? Yes.
This weapon served a purpose and it's got
its own style in terms of how it's used.
Again, in fantasy,
we can do whatever we want,
but the idea is
you've got all these pointy bits,
you're going to use all of them and you're
going to train to use all of them.
So we’ve taken a look at daggers
and taken a look at a broadsword,
taken a look at a war axe,
all inspired from Witcher: Blood Origin,
which is out now on Netflix.
Make sure you go check it out.
There’s some really cool
fight scenes in it.
Stephen, Luke,
thank you so much for joining us
and showing us how to use these weapons
cinematically on screen.
Thanks again. It's always a pleasure.
I always have a good time with you guys.
Heck yeah. Same here.
And you know, I'm curious,
you know, to all of you watching,
if you had to go into battle,
which one of these three would you pick?
Daggers, Broadsword, or war axe.
Let us know in the comments below
and see you maybe in another Punch 4 Punch
at some point.
You like. us! Yeah.
Maybe leave some comments about that too.
All right. So long, everybody.
Happy holidays.